welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Loki
season 2 episode 4 which hilariously
blows up in our faces any hot takes we
had about who was calling Loki and any
hopes we had for Victor timely's future
unless it was at a pasta night but damn
that's what I love about this show let's
break down this episode shop by shop for
all the Easter eggs visual details
timeline logic and clues to find out how
we can all avoid a horrible Demise by
spaghettification or time Cube crushing
this season just keeps getting better
and better and a big part of this ride
is being able to share this with you all
you've all been so supportive and
wonderful each week so thank you for
giving new rock stars some of your time
after every Loki episode please consider
supporting us by grabbing our amazing
new OB inspired shirt available at nerd
rot. shop thanks to Rocket money for
sponsoring today's video more about them
in a minute now we don't get the full
Marvel Studios title card package this
week we just jump straight to the green
card and then it gets blown toward us as
we find ourselves inside of the surging
sacred timeline like the opening of
season 1 episode 6 and yeah we're going
to spend some time on the sounds that we
can try to make out from this opening 10
seconds listen
[Applause]
closely actually for good measure let's
listen
[Applause]
again now when we were in this space in
the opening of the season one finale the
sound mixer is actually snuck in a ton
of sound bites from MCU history and real
world history and I'm willing to bet
that they did the same thing here but
these are just kind of harder to make
out though I do think I can start to
separate some sounds out we do hear some
Whispering at the top followed by a
shouting voice that kind of sounds like
[Applause]
Loki as the title card swipes away it
sounds like a group of people chanting
something almost like the witches and
Agatha's Coven in W division when they
chanted Moors monstro
natural no I cannot control
it then we hear a long wailing voice
from a male character that kind of
sounds like Doctor Strange following
through the Multiverse and Multiverse of
Madness then a few other
screams and I really do think one of
them might be this scream
and then it ends on what sounds like a
woman
chuckling that almost sounds like the
voice of Agatha Harkness and obviously I
brought up Agatha twice here I just love
kathern Han everything kind of sounds
like her voice to me really I think what
we are hearing are just the screams of
Terror and confusion of everyone on
these Branch timelines breaking off from
the sacred timeline as all of these
histories collide with each other and
form incursions when we last saw this
Citadel Ro in the season 1 finale there
was more order to everything like there
was a solid curved sacred timeline a
Dark Void Beyond it an intact asteroid
with a citadel on top with the light on
but now it's all scrambled together the
asteroid has broken up into chunks the
timeline now streaks in various
directions like lightning the blues
swirling in with the purples I mentioned
in last week's breakdown that the design
choice to give the asteroid and the
Citadel kintsugi crack patterns ended up
foreshadowing that this place was
designed to crumble because gave these
fissures preset fault lines to follow
Miss minutes conjures an orange scan of
the room which visually reminds me of
the tech used by Gwen Stacy and Jessica
Drew in across's sperse to reconstruct
Jonathan own's apartment crime scene in
both cases it shows us that this
multiversal network keeps digital 3D
scans of all history to play it back
when they need to M minutes uses this
scan to create a dollhous sized version
of the room which is interesting because
that's something he remains did to talk
about his backstory but one thing to
note here is that there are two chairs
with their backs to the window and no
desk inside this smaller version so this
wasn't a formal study for he who remains
to WR right right right right it was
really a lounge for two people to sit
and enjoy each other's company Ren
slayer's face looms large in the window
frame Behind These recordings so it's
almost ready a Utopia at the end of time
for us for all time always this is the
recording Loki herd in the past TVA back
in season 2 episode 1 for us for all all
time always Prof Rin Slayer you are
quite a Marvel Rin Slayer wears her
Hunter uniform which I will remind you
is marked a23 a nod to 1963's Avengers
number 23 the debut of Princess Rona
Riner as a disinterested love interest
to Kang the Conqueror her wearing
tactical gear here tells us that we are
right at the end of the multiversal war
and that Rin Slayer tipped it by
choosing to help this Kang variant tame
elith if these two are variants of each
other and r Slayer is his female variant
it could have been similar to Loki and
soie needing to join hands to tame elith
and that's how he remains and ren Slayer
did it to use elith to prune all other
King's timelines to win this war in this
shot he remains head is framed in front
of Ren slayer's cheek where a teardrop
would be notice Major's delivery on I
will be proud to lead with
you you made a difference in this
war thank you for being on my team it's
clear that he remains just can't stomach
a true partnership he remains says that
he'll catch up in a bit a long
road see you soon see you soon these
were his final words for Sylvie in the
season 1 finale see you soon and the
words the timekeeper Android had said
after it was
beheaded he remains then repeats the
word always and he puts his hands
together in a brief prayer pose which is
what he did did to mockingly praise the
timekeepers as being the
[Music]
gods Miss minutes pops up to offer a
game of chess she told Victor last
episode that her original function was
as a chessmate to he remains but instead
he says pull up protocol
42 is it time erase her memories there's
that pesky number 42 again obligatory
reminder that 42 is the answer to the
great question in Douglas Adams
hitchhiker guide books it is Miles
Morales spider's Universe number in the
spiderverse films it's Jackie Robinson's
number 42 showed up on the laundry
ticket and everything everywhere all at
once a movie that also starred KIU Kuan
42 was on Ripley's pulse rifle and
aliens and most recently 42 was a
compartment of x5's temp pad that Loki
was prodding back in episode 2 see
screenwriters and set decorators just
love to plug 42 in everywhere but also
we should note that 42 was the final of
the six recurring numbers of lost
preceded by it's worth noting 23 which
was friend Slayer Hunter ID wait a
minute 15 is B1 15's ID so now we just
got to find a 16 an 8 and a four and we
get a free fish cookie from the darh
initiative poly bear cage but in this
case protocol 42 has The Vibes of
Execute Order 66 because it erases the
memories of not just RN Slayer but
everyone currently in the TVA this was
something he had previously discussed
with Miss minut Miss minutes confirms to
Ren Slayer you didn't just help it was
you who commanded the
army so he built this little Tower yeah
notice how dust Falls timed perfectly as
Ren slayer's understanding of her
history crumbles Miss minute says that
they don't need him and maybe they never
did like the opening shot of the Season
we are back to a big face of he who
remains but this time it is part of the
wall of the War Room that Loki had
pruned back Victor timle steps right
through it through his own face this
particular face will come back as a
recurring image throughout the episode
in a very important moment later on in
fact this will be the face that spells
his own Doom throughout these opening
minutes we hear the sound kind of like
groaning metal right before building
collapses it's kind of like he remains
is on a sinking ship which is
interesting because he cut Rona loose
last episode on a Lifeboat and said he
is on the ship that will be sinking the
PA overhead announces Chronos centers
11294 offline and then later Chronos
centers
32817 offline Victor checks out the
murals in the corner where Loki Mobi is
chatted back in the season 2 premiere
depicting the timekeepers into the left
Waring Kang variants one of these is
probably the one who shoved him back in
the 1860s of Chicago when he was a baby
Mobius tells him here's the deal you
have to trust us and we don't have time
I'm from Chicago friend the shadrac
capital of the world I don't trust
anyone Shad theocracy that's not a word
kind of sounds like a word he just made
up because you know he is a con man he's
just kind of making up stuff all the
time but if we break down the parts of
the word shade means harm and chissy
means rule so kind of the rule by harm
which does align with how Chicago has
been dubbed the windy city not just for
the cold wind off Lake Michigan but as
some theorize from an 1890 article by
New York Sun editor Charles Dana
complained about Chicago's corrupt moves
to secure the hosting of the world's
fair that the city's politicians were
full of hot air the windy city however
according to history.com enologist Barry
popic cited earlier headlines from
rivaling Midwestern CI calling Chicago
by that term like an 1876 headline from
the Cincinnati Inquirer that was meant
to be double-edged for a tornado that
hit Chicago but also for the city
speakers that were full of wind this is
your Chicago History lesson of this week
all right so B15 tells judge gamble that
docs and the others are in holding and
gamble tells her you kind of need to
forgive her we need all the help we can
get right now on the Chrono monitor
screen we see the words Loom unstable
flashing and we see how there are way
more red lines in the danger zone than
we last Saw down on the RNA level we
start with this close-up of the hot
coffee hot chocolate and soup machine
that will later enchant Victor timley
Casey works on a small monitor that
displays core displac VA 234 map which I
presume shows the throughput diameter of
the Loom Victor meets OB and this is a
fascinating moment oh
B Ora Boris or Boris responds but I
learned everything I know from a
brilliant 19 century inventor in them
Victor timely if we had the resources he
would have been bigger than
Einstein
[Music]
in little detail we hear the sound of a
pneumatic tube in effect showing ob's
realization like what and this tube
coming in right now come on TVA you're
in an existential crisis why are you
giving OB more busy work he remains
always originated from a 19th century
variant and despite what happens to
Victor timley this episode in some past
historical cycle some Victor timley went
on to successfully build the TVA from
this notebook inspiring OG OB in the
process but is that the case I have a
whole separate video breaking down who
actually built the TVA based off of this
chicken in an egg Paradox here it's just
interesting that despite he remains
wiping all their memories in these past
Cycles OB still remembers the name
Victor timley as if it was just a name
plucked from history this is another
example of OB being immune to everything
else he remains or mis minutes due in
the TVA I just think he is equally
important to the tva's founding he was
there when it started and these men just
kind of influenced each other Loki says
so if your work is based on his work and
his work is based on your work exactly
which came from it's like a snake eating
its own tail a snake eating its own tail
an obvious nod to the mythological root
of the term or aoris it is a snake
eating its own tail the idea here is
that it is a self-fulfilling prophecy
both men influenced each other in
different ways through different cycles
of history because time is a flat circle
this stuff kind of just repeats itself
so while from Victor timy's perspective
he just received this book and oror
inspired him to be a great inventor or
Boris in his own history was inspired by
a Victor timley from the sacred timeline
who was a brilliant Kang be AR who was
just placed at that point in history
with ahead of his time thinking that
inspired or Boris in the TBA it's Victor
timy's Destiny to become a he remains
that inspires OB and it's ob's Destiny
to become a hardworking member of the
TVA to inspire Victor timley what we are
seeing here is What's called the
grandfather Paradox or the bootstrap
Paradox time travel movies are filled
with examples of this like how Marty
McFly pushes his dad out of the way of
the car thus preventing his parents from
falling in love and having him which
means he wouldn't have been able to
travel back in time to prevent them from
falling in love see it's kind of a parad
box there I quickly want to point out
this take a tab dispenser in the
background with just a bunch of tickets
sticking out of it again no one has
visited OB in hundreds of years so you
know this just made me laugh there's
also a sign on one of the shelves that
just reads tacos maybe instead of key
lime pie they used to have a taco
Tuesday and then behind Casey in this
one angle is a new poster we haven't
seen yet prevent self- pruning service
your time stick every 674 minutes I
think that's what that says which would
be every 11 and A4 hours that's very
very often servicing one stick twice per
day there are some gross places to take
that but rather than a kind of Suicide
Prevention PSA so that no one pulls a
season 1 episode 5 Sylvie it suggests
that pruning sticks need frequent
recharging and upkeep or they'll
malfunction and cause the user to
accidentally sell prune OB Wheels out
this model here's a model I locked up of
the Loom for give the shy and slap flash
work it's not too scale I only got one
coat of paint on there and Mobius
compliments him okay I think you're
being a little hard on yourself OB it
looks great all right and Obie smiles
yeah this is a direct reference to the
model walkthrough scene and Back to the
Future please excuse the crudity of this
model I didn't have time to build it to
scale or to paint it it's good oh thank
you thank you I love this joke because
in both cases the models look freaking
great but Engineers are often
perfectionists apologizing for projects
that are easily the best working class
the way OB walks through it is pretty
much the same way Doc Brown walks us
through the Hill Valley Town Square
minus the figurine ended up catching on
fire but I think that's a joke too
because what's at the the far end of
that walkway Victor timley he's going to
be the one who walks this walk and faces
a similarly Grizzly explosive end as OB
hops the figurine down the gang way
behind Victor we actually see this sign
in case people didn't hear OV it reads
not to scale and I love how that little
red sign has a TVA logo at the top of it
like this is something that OB printed
out thinking it would be official TVA
usage on a regular basis to label things
not to scale OB says the throughput
multiplier will manage the backlog of
branches that was created
when someone killed he who remains and
released all those branches and ruined
my life yeah Sylvie proudly smiles when
the stabbing of he who remains is
brought up but she has no reaction when
Obie says this ruined his life Loki and
Mobi is bicker over whose shape the
figurine better matches and I'm
surprised B is considers himself the
Slimmer of the two after all the pie
he's been eating Victor provides his own
throughput multiplier as a solution and
he tells OB Mr or Boris if anyone
can it's you
and
me Sylvie senses something disturbing
about this partnership because since
both these men inspired each other a
handshake is really more self-
congratulatory like you know servicing
one's stick she senses that there could
be another he remains and there's more
to the story of how the TVA got founded
movus and Loki head out passing a sign
engineering personnel only are you meant
to be down here with a very grumpy
looking engineer makes me wonder if the
rarely attended TVA automat might be
only for employees on this level of
which there's only one OB and that could
be why OB is resistant to pass TVA
memory wipes Sylvie calls out mobus for
wanting pie and we get another reminder
that Mobius is weirdly unconcerned with
his sacred timeline life and she's so
upset because she knows the atrisk
branch is broon McDonald's Jack who I
think could be a young Mobius yeah I'm
going to keep beating that drum Sylvia
here is lit from behind making her face
somewhat shadowed whereas Mobius is set
like an interrogation room harsh light
right over his head completely dark
background so we could see every
reaction on his face as Sylvie calls him
out you know who's good with money Tony
Stark you know who's good with rockets
Iron Man even if you're not super rich
or a superhero you can supercharge your
finances by using rocket money the
all-in-one Finance platform that helps
you save more and spend less God
unwanted subscription payments rocket
money can take care of those for you
rocket money can also deposit your money
into a smart savings account help you
understand your spending with its
budgeting tool and even help negotiate
bills once you sign up for free you can
unlock even more features with premium
I've been using rocket money's smart
savings account for ages and because of
that I was able to save up for a trip to
New York I just took a plane instead of
you know a Mark 7 to try rocket money
out now and support our Channel head to
Rocket money.com neww rockstars or click
the link in the video's description
meanwhile in prisoner holding General
doc sits in the center of the room her
chair directly over the crushed table
that we saw last episode while the
others hover near the perimeter of the
room doc knows that being crushed with a
Time cube in this room is likely and as
the leader of the group she is sitting
here to say you know what just crush me
don't crush the others who are just
following my orders Brad says if we just
try to figure this out we can get out of
this room and we can get back to our
lives I believe it was Galileo or or
Winston Church cut the it's pretty
funny that he mixes these two up
considering he works for an agency that
oversees all of history Galileo was an
Italian astronomer born in 1564 Winston
Churchill a British prime minister born
in 1874 the two had very little in
common actually it's interesting though
that he brings up Galileo because
Galileo was Tried by the Roman
Inquisition in 1615 he was branded a
heretic for his heliocentric ISM Theory
and throughout his life he had to recant
parts of his theories to avoid death as
B15 talks to them Brad rests his hands
on his collar the same way he used to
his chest plate in previous episodes
when he was wearing his Hunter uniform
just the color just seems like kind of
an awkward thing to be holding on to
that way as B15 checks in with D90
outside we see this room is labeled CCC
073 and it's in the same part of the TVA
with that slanted curved wall that we
saw in season 1 episode 4 when Loki and
Sylvie were detained Loki's
interrogation room didn't look like this
so it kind of seems like they have
different interior designs for these
cells depending on what psychological
State they want their inmates to be in
meanwhile in the automat we get a closer
look at the pie drawers despite there
only being one flavor they still label
every drawer and it looks like it costs
three tokens per slice compare this to
the one token it cost to get a cup of
hot cocoa Sylvie ended up here after
taking a wrong turn this automat really
just kind of seems like an odd dead end
that absent-minded wandering employees
always wander back to Loki passes this
poster bring your own cup if you forget
remember it next time we do not provide
cups or employ dishwashers so why
doesn't the TVA have a food service
staff what do they want people to forget
is left over on these plates hold that
thought I'm going to blow your mind ly
Recaps the events of the Thor film some
years ago my brother was banished from
Asgard and sent to Earth and when he
came back he was different changed
somehow I thought it was weakness I
mocked him
is that it gone soft Thor actually was
Stronger at the end of this having
proved himself worthy of wielding Moler
and ultimately defeating Loki but since
this Loki got taken from the year 2012
on the timeline that would have been the
second most recent battle that he had
gone through and I just like that the
events of this Loki series have matured
him on a similar path that the events of
Thor of the Dark World did and Ragnarok
did Loki tells Sylvie that destruction
is easy but fixing things is hard and
hope itself is hard actually the Norse
rune for Hope actually looks a lot like
a branch timeline you could say the
sentiment is similar to the one Loki
expressed to Sylvia in episode 2 when he
said it's harder to stay Loki declares
that you can't just give people Free
Will and walk away that it's up to them
to do better than he remains de sounds
like whatever we do we're playing
God we are Gods now while you could see
this line as Loki finding a way to
justify his is this not easier speech
from the 2012 Avengers I love the
decision to frame this line from Loki in
wide cuz if Loki were in closeup the
line we a Gods would look kind of proud
and Powerful but since they are so small
in the frame it makes them look
powerless and minuscule conceeding to an
immense burden to look after the average
people while getting no praise or thanks
for it like humans raise statues to Thor
to Odin to freaking balder the brave but
not to Loki he's doing a thankless task
Ren Slayer and Miss minutes arrive in
prisoner holding making an offer to
General docs and her people anyone who
joins me right here follows me out that
door and helps me restore stability to
the TVA will have a life on on the
timeline if they want it remember this
is the same offer Miss minutes made to
Sylvie and to Loki before they push
forward to get past her to he remains in
the season one finale When Miss minutes
goes in and out of the time Cube machine
to activate it she comes out with this
devilish little grin like she's enjoying
this way too much waiter when the cube
begins to Titan Miss minutes becomes
overwhelmed with Glee She is evil Miss
minut and BR Slayer know just from
Brad's inability to look Doc in the eyes
that he doesn't need to be contained in
the cube he has made its decision and
what follows is one of the most horrific
deaths we have seen in the MCU he had
somehow the second most horrific death
this episode we stay on Brad's face for
most of this in only one brief moment
does he open his eyes to look into Doc's
eyes but then he promptly closes them
and then only looks above the cube
because again with that graded floor
they would be crushed in a viscera and
that would ooze down to the drain I'm
sorry to dwell on this too much but the
last thing each of these poor people
felt was the Flesh of each other it's
one thing to get crushed alone in a Time
Cube because the walls of it would be
your greatest enemy but to do it to a
group of people makes each other's
bodies that thing that ends up killing
you and that is just unimaginably cruel
later when B15 finds the remains we only
see her reaction but we hear the sound a
steamy Sizzle which makes me think that
their viscera is still
bubbling B15 tries to access Diagnostics
on her temp pad uh uhuh access denied uh
n to Dennis nre's computer in Jurassic
Park uhuh you didn't say the magic word
Loki season one director Kate Heron said
that Miss minutes was partly inspired by
Jurassic parks Mr DNA character but
notice how we edit directly from the
steamy heat lines over B15 face to the
bubbling hot cocoa as it Globs into the
cup that had to be intentional like the
remains are draining directly into this
cup before the season back in August I
theorized that the green pie could be a
nod to soilent green and that it is made
of people when they're killed when we do
see The Killing Room in soilent green we
should note the Comfort color the man
chooses is the color orange so maybe all
the sweets that mobus has been consuming
in the TVA are the remains of his
co-workers my theory back in August was
that the soilent green pie is designed
to leave the TVA Employees doped up to
keep them on task to keep them from
asking the right questions I'll admit
when I posed this theory in that August
15th video I didn't think anything would
come from it but sure enough I am pretty
surprised to see it possible right now
after sipping the hot cocoa D90
constricts and he prunes and we think
for a second it's because of the drink
but no it is X5 behind him pruning D90
in the back hiding himself just like
Loki will do to his time slipping self
later and when the hot coco hits the
floor notice where X5 is looking when he
says I'm sorry he is looking down at the
Coco as he says this could he know that
the sweets contain his former comrades
or at least reminded of their juices
slashing on the floor actually can we
get an next five does he know thumbnail
does he know later when they see the
spill on the ground it kind of looks
like a person with two arms outstretched
trying to crawl away I know I'm totally
reaching but I just want my hot hot
summer Theory to be true back in the RNA
Department ob's computer scans Mobius
temp pad anomalies reports 32 files Loop
computation 23 fil temporal either 616
or s16 which would mean we found A6
punch that ABC lost numbers punch card
and that's uh 2252 files then Chicago
logs 3,325 files and variance reports 23
files now that fourth one might not be
the word Chicago but Chicago logs is
what you get after you eat lumantis and
portelos in the same day Obi asks Mobius
did you download unauthorized games
again no I'm not going to make that
mistake twice I really hope the game
that Mobius downloaded was a jet ski one
but also OB remembers this past
violation despite Mobius only
remembering meeting OB like two days ago
so did Mobius recently download a game
to his temp pad in the past 48 hours or
something while they were dealing with
this crisis Mobius says timely's gone
Miss minutes is back yeah Mobius here
it's the cash register thing sound
effect that we started hearing with Miss
minutes back in episode 3 but then they
drag Victor into the War Room Miss b
stands on the table directly in front of
the wall where the he remains faces are
showing how her goal is to supplant he
remains in episode 3 she projected her
face over a mannequin to Signal her want
of a corporeal body now she projects
herself over he remains face to show her
ambition to take over the TVA the loom
overload escalates and we see gold
colored bands exploding like spaghetti
boiling out of a pot spilling over the
first ring meanwhile on the right side
of the Loom the timeline it is forming
doesn't really look that great either a
lot of times in the MCU CGI and swirling
animated glowing energy just kind of
looks like nothing having no weight but
every shot we've seen of this thing the
fact that they refer to it as a tangible
archaic Artisan tool a loom just makes
it a fascinating thing to look at every
time over the PA we
[Applause]
hear ah Loki now recognizes this sound
because it's the same one he heard back
at the end of the season 2 premiere he
suspects he is caught up to that point
in the future as I mentioned in the
episode one breakdown the sirens going
off the Panic the Melt down countdown
reminds me of season two have lost when
the numbers have run down they didn't
punch the code in time and Desmond has
to turn the fail safe key below the
hatch the hatch explodes but he ends up
okay he's just kind of naked in sort of
unstuck in time experiencing the future
I think that's what's going to happen to
Loki in the next two episodes now they
approached the loom room X-Men doors
we're now calling them by the way these
doors plus some graffiti I definitely
did not spot in episode 2 that
apparently read all M are brothers
according to screen rant's interview
with d delu these were not really
planned they might have just been an art
Department thing but Dand delu said that
his teacher once told his class when it
comes to inferring meaning without
stated authorial intent quote well if
it's there it's there so make of that
what you will I think the cooler detail
about this entrance to the loom room are
these little symbols above the threshold
on either side of mortal danger these
look like the Loki series version of
Something referred to as semiotic
standard this is actually something I
uncovered in my deep dive of Ridley
Scott's alien Semitic standard is a
pictographic signage system developed by
designer Ron Cobb for the Interiors of
the stroo referring to cautions or
things you can find in the next part of
the ship it's honestly one of my
favorite discoveries in Hollywood
science fiction because ever since alien
sci-fi production designers have used
variations on semiotic standard
everywhere like you could see it in the
2009 same Rockwell movie Moon trust me
you're going to start to see these
little semiotic standard signs and
everything and here above the X door are
a whole bunch of TVA semiotic standard
signs probably only readable by OB
probably every warning they have in the
book and now we Circle back to the same
imagery we saw in the season 2 episode 1
episode F Loki or time slipping Loki
with his shirt sleeve slash and bloody
holding the meter looking for a pruning
stick but now we see it from A New
Perspective Sylvie is stuck in Mis
minute sabotaged elevator in episode 4
Loki with the jacket retracing his steps
and seeing himself from behind back in
season 2 episode 1 you could actually
see that episode 4 Loki in a brief shot
behind episode one Loki in the shadows
just out of focus and like Harry Potter
realizing he was the one who sent the
Patronis to his past self and prisoner
of ataban Loki realizes what he has to
do and he prunes his past self he has to
close the loop just like he remains is
trying to close the loop with Victor
timley and it requires a kind of self-
pruning despite the Waring on the poster
in the RNA we saw earlier and then we
finally get an answer to who was calling
on the phone hello about time what's
taking you guys so long we had all of
these theories on who might be on the
other end of that line and everyone from
Loki himself to Thor was put forward as
a possibility this is one subversion of
expectations I'm totally okay with Ubie
warns that if they take Mis minutes
offline they'll lose the other functions
of the TVA the dampners that prevent
people from using magic at the TVA turn
off yes both Loki and Sylvie have been
so frustrated to be unable to use their
magic inside the TVA of course this is
how two variants of each other would
respond Miss minut begins to reboot and
some fascinating stuff happens here
someone's trying to reboot the system I
can't access it I'm being locked out
locked out well marking this just isn't
NE yeah Victor doesn't know what digital
glitching looks like so he just assumes
she's stuttering to make fun of him but
her glitching began with her facial dial
spinning clockwise and then she goes
through her reboot Victor I need to tell
you I need to tell
you you'll never be him some really cool
visual details here binary code of ones
and zeros fill her body and X's form
over her eyes as if she's dead but she
summons a final breath to tell Victor
you'll never be him with one eye
glitched out like a villainous missing
eye and then she disappears to reveal
the background face she's once again
perfectly aligned with the true he
remains we briefly see a floppy disc in
the words a problem has been detected
and system will shut down to prevent
damage and then collecting data for
crash dump initializing disc for crash
dump beginning dump of physical memory
Computing critical memory to dis and
critical is misspelled also crash dump
that's what you get at the end of the
day that you double dipped on lumon nais
and Portillos the TVA logo flashes for a
split second with dollar signs and an
hourglass logo formed above and then a
very basic version of Mis minutes with
arms and legs but just a clock face with
no eyes or mouth but 12 3 6 and nine and
those numbers kind of jump around on the
face and immediately after she
disappears the focus shifts from where
she just was to that centered version of
he remains face looking like he is
glaring at Victor timley for
disappointing him so what did Miss
minutes mean by you'll never be him I
think she is calling back the fact that
he cut off her sentence back in episode
3 and instead of saying I love you she's
saying the most cutting thing and
cutting for ways we do not yet Realize
by saying this to him and by forcing him
to look into the eyes of his alternate
self she is putting a chip on his
shoulder she is dooming Victor into
playing the hero and making a stupid
decision she's setting a self-fulfilling
prophecy for him Sylvia immediately
enchants Brad using the same body
control magic that she used in season 1
episode 2 in the Rock card Superstore so
we get this fun bit of the actor Rafael
Cal doing a silie impression X5 what's
going
on this is he I didn't think I'd see you
again so soon Ren Slayer gets pruned and
because of the outfit she is wearing her
outline looks like an hourglass
resembling the multicolored painting of
The Hourglass on the wall that Loki
Sylvie And Timely run by just a second
later Victor sticks his head in the
temporal Aura scanner and the computer
opens up welcome he who remains notice
that the voice is male now because it is
not miss minutes now above their heads
on the ceiling there is this Dome shaped
dial and now we can see several numbers
on it from the right there's 972 858 778
723 and wait a minute is that 616 on the
other side of it it starts with zero
then 46 and then a few others but if
that is 616 these all could correspond
to Universe numbers none of the other
ones really matched up for me but Earth
723 does refer to a universe where the
world is Unified by music that's from a
2006 star brand comic I don't know the
needles of this dial spin past all of
these numbers it's not really clear what
they refer to but Victor volunteers to
take the throughput multiplier out to
the loom just in case something goes
wrong he was spurred by Miss minutes
telling him you'll never be him put the
chip on Victor's shoulder he should not
be doing this because what makes a he
remains is a he who remains not one who
goes out to be the hero but a coward who
stays behind let other people kill
themselves which leads to This brilliant
[Applause]
moment okay I'm going to give you all a
sense of how shockingly tall I am with a
standing ovation to Marvel for actually
doing this Victor timely within seconds
spaghettify actually if you look closely
the VFX artist made his bones visible
you can see a rib cage a spine even a
skull Jawbone that means Victor timley
felt the flesh spaghetti py off his
bones it got handed to Jonathan Majors
for his blood curling scream under that
helmet each spaghetti strand even
disappears after the fact just one final
one puffing into a smoke ring like the
Scot Lang doppelganger in the
probability storm in Ant-Man the was
quamania and what w maxoff did to Reed
Richards a guy who is technically
related to Victor timley his body turned
turns into spaghetti which is actually a
concept in theoretical physics when one
would enter a black hole in fact Victor
timley was rushed into this room so fast
he probably didn't take a beat to read
what was on the floor warning about this
and actually in the final frames after
you see Victor Chim Le's skull a blast
of light pulses out from the strands
which I think could be Victor's temporal
Aura leaving his body I think that Miss
minut telling Victor you'll never be him
was an intentional move by her to get
him to do something stupid like this
she's the one who put him on a course
toward his own death and why did she do
that because she wants to screw over he
remains failsafe plan because his plan
for his successor to complete his Loop
has now been broken there is no he who
actually remained anymore and I love how
we get individual reaction shots for
each character and then kind of a shared
reaction in real time as the camera
moves from person to person they each
have an individual distinct moment for
themselves but Casey has the funniest
reaction what did we do wrong I don't
know what happened I don't know it
wasn't me the poor guy after years of
being looked down and bullied by the
hunters who went by his desk right now
he just wants everyone to know that this
wasn't his fault Loki says I don't know
and there's something chilling this time
when Tom hson says I don't know he spent
this episode assuring everyone that
things would be okay when he completed
his own Loop of Destiny he had so much
confidence thinking for once he was in
control of his fate and now he realizes
no way he had told Sylvie that their
mission now had to be rebuilding the TVA
now he doesn't even know what his
purpose is or what all of this was even
for the loom explodes enveloping all of
the branches and sending a wall of
radiation blasting toward them we are
seeing the tva's Ragnarok event sub that
this Loki never actually lived through
if you think about it we are seeing the
bursting of a dam flooding them but if
you think about it couldn't you see a
dam as something that was violating
nature I'm going to be getting into that
in a video I've coming out this weekend
but the light gets brighter and brighter
until Loki has to shut his eyes against
it and then everything stops we just cut
to Black like it's a final shot of The
Sopranos what comes after death maybe
nothing isn't that the ultimate fear now
the closing credits casting photo screen
includes a photo of Loki pruning himself
he remains in Rin Slayer in the Citadel
Mobius after Sylvie told him off OB
meeting Victor and Victors time to be
brave Death March so what comes next
season 1 episode 4 ended with what we
thought was a death of Loki but really
just ended up being his transference to
somewhere else the void I suspect a
similarly trippy episode 5 of this
season remaining unseen trailer footage
suggests that we are in store for lots
more parts of the TVA spaghetti fine and
Loki has some more time slipping to do
headed to piranha Power Sports where he
will find Mobius in a jet ski
transaction really I think Loki could
try to time slip again back to an
earlier hour or earlier day sometime
within in the TBA to try to prevent this
crisis sooner Maybe by taking Victor's
Place because we know that the dampeners
are off Loki can use some of his sorcery
he may try to take Victor's Place or
maybe Mobius is place all the way back
in season 2 episode 1 hell he may time
slip back to the Citadel with Sylvie and
with he who remains Jonathan Majors was
reported to appear in three out of six
episodes this season so we may end this
season with a replay of the season 1
finale with Loki and Sylvie continuing
their conversation in the Citadel with
the original he remains good God
everyone Loki season 2 has it all I
don't think I've ever had so much fun
analyzing episodes of a Marvel series
comment down below where you think these
final two episodes are going to go from
here again our OB shirt is just amazing
I'm going to be wearing it all the time
from here on out so grab one for
yourself and celebrate with me nerd rot.
shop subscribe to all three channels in
the new rockstars Network thank you to
Gina EO for helping me write this
breakdown follow me at eaos and I'll see
you next week bye
[Music]
everybody